PROFESSOR: The final
general counting rules
that we'll examine is
called inclusion-exclusion,
and it is a straightforward
generalization of the sum
rule-- at least in the
simple case of two sets
that we'll look at first.
So we're going to look at
6042 example of applying
inclusion-exclusion, but let's
begin by stating what it is.
So the sum of the rule
says that if you have two
sets A and B that are disjoint--
no overlap between A and B--
then the size of A union B
is equal to the size of A
plus the size of the
B. Well that's obvious.
We took that as
kind of basic axiom.
But what if they're
not disjoint?
Suppose that A and B
overlap, and there's
some stuff in here that's
the intersection of A and B
where there are points
in common, what then
is the size of A union B
in terms of simpler things
that we can count?
And the answer is that the size
of A union B is the size of A
plus the size of B minus the
size of A intersection B.
Now, the intuitive reason for
that-- and it's not really
very hard to make a
precise argument--
is that when you're adding
up the elements in A,
you're counting all the elements
of the intersection once.
And then when you add in the
elements in B here-- A plus B--
you're counting all the
elements in the intersection
a second time.
The ones that are in A
minus B get counted once.
The ones that are in B
minus A get counted once,
but the ones that are
in A intersection B
get counted twice.
So to get the
right count, I have
to subtract the
size of A minus B
so it's only counted once
in the total formula,
and that's an intuitive
explanation of why
inclusion-exclusion
formula holds for two sets.
Let's apply it.
And I'm going to
look at an example
where we're looking
at digit permutations,
and I'm going to look at
permutations of the 10
digits, 0 through 9 inclusive.
There's a standard one where
they're listed in order,
and there is just a
random seeming permutation
of the digits 0 through 9.
Notice that the 1 and 3-- the
2 is sort of out of order.
The rest are in order.
Now, what I'm going
to be interested in
is those permutations where
certain patterns appear.
So first of all, let's
note it that the number
of permutations we know how
to count-- it's 10 factorial.
I'm interested in
how many permutations
have a consecutive 6 and
0, a consecutive 0 and 4,
or a consecutive 4 and 2.
In other words, two of
the consecutive numbers
that appear in 6042.
Well, the first one does not.
There's no 60, 04,
or 42 in this list.
This one has a 42.
So it would count as one of
those permutations that has
either a 60, a 04, or 42
because it's got the 42.
Here's one where
you've got a 2 and a 4,
but that's not a 4 and a 2.
And in fact, there is no
pattern here of 60, 04, 42.
So it's not one of
the permutations
that I'm interested in.
On the other hand, here's
one that's doubly good.
This is a permutation that has
both a 04 in it and a 42 in it.
So it would be one of these
permutations of the kind that
I'm looking for that has at
least one of the pattern 60,
04, or 42.
Well, if I let P sub
x be the permutations
with the sub-sequence x,
then what I'm really saying
is that this one with
a 42 in it is in P 42
because it's got the 42 pattern.
This one with the 04 and a
42 in it is in the P 04 set
of permutations with the pattern
04 intersected with the set
of patterns that have a 42.
So that's what that
one illustrates.
So what we're really asking
for then is the union of three
things-- the union of
P 60, P 04, and P 42.
How big is the set of
sequences that have a 60 union,
the set of things
that have a 04 union,
that have a 42?
And as we saw illustrated
in the previous slide,
these are not disjoint.
We'll I've been
cheating a little
because in order to
figure out this one,
I'm going to need
inclusion-exclusion
for three sets instead of
two, which is slightly more
complicated because I have
a union of three things that
overlap.
And let's look at that.
So what does inclusion-exclusion
look like for three sets?
If I want to know what's the
size of A union B union C,
here's a Venn diagram
that shows a picture
of A union B union C with
all possible overlaps
illustrated there.
And the formula turns out to
be-- you add up A, B, and C.
You add up the size of A, the
size of B, and the size of C.
Now that has a consequence that
just that sum of A, B, and C
is counting this
lens shaped region
that is the
intersection of A and C.
It's counting it twice
in the A plus C term.
It's counting A
intersection B twice,
and it's counting
this lens shape, which
is C intersection B twice.
So in order to
get the sum right,
I'm going to have to
subtract one occurrence
of A intersection B, one
A intersection C, one B
intersection C so that those
items are only counted once
in this sum.
And then in fact, if
you look at this region
here, of the sort of rounded
triangle region-- which
is the intersection
of A with B and C--
that one is actually
getting counted three times.
All three circles overlap it.
So when I add in A and I
add in B and I add in C,
every one of those points there
is being added three times.
On the other hand, this
rounded triangle shape,
which is count of three times
in the sum A plus B plus C,
is being subtracted three times.
Because when I look at A
intersection B-- this region--
and I subtract it, I'm taking
one away from the count
on each point there.
And likewise with A
intersection C, takes one away.
And B intersection
C takes one away.
Leaving the points in the
rounded triangle in A intersect
B intersection C
not counted at all.
So if I'm going to get the total
count right so that every point
discounted exactly
once, I have to add back
in the intersection
of A and B and C.
So that's an
informal explanation
of how the inclusion-exclusion
formula works for three sets.
We'll look at ways to rigorously
prove inclusion-exclusion
for an arbitrary number
of sets shortly but not
in this segment.
Let's go on and apply the
inclusion-exclusion rule
for three sets to the example
of digit permutations with
the patterns 60, 04, and 42.
And the way to remember this
is that the intersections
of an even number of
sets occur negatively,
the intersection of
an odd number of sets
occur positively, and of
course, a single set can
be thought of just am
intersection of one
set with itself.
So it's also odd and
occurs positively.
All right.
Well, now we can apply the
formula and say that the set
of permutations that
have a 60, a 04,
and a 42 is equal to the sum
of the number that have a 60,
the number that have a 04, and
the number that have a 42 minus
the numbers that have two of the
patterns minus those that have
all three patterns.
At let's count these individual
intersections and sets of
permutations separately.
It turns out that each one
is easy to count, which
is a typical situation which
is why inclusion-exclusion
is a valuable principle because
this thing that is harder
to count can be broken
up into counting
a bunch of other
things-- intersections--
that are often easier to count.
And they will be here.
So let's begin by
looking at P 60.
P 60 is the set of permutations
which have a 60 in them.
Well, to count them, we can
think about it this way.
Think of the patterns
with a 60 in them
as a permutation of nine items--
the digits 1 through 5 and 7
through 9 and the object 60 that
you can place anywhere, but it
it's got to be lumped together.
So there are really nine
possible permutations
of these things-- eight of
them digits, and one of them
is this pair of digits, 60.
And the number of
those permutations
is equal to the number of
permutations with the pattern
60.
So the answer is there are
9 factorial permutations
with the pattern 60.
Same of course, applies
to P 04, and P 42.
The number of permutations
with a given two digit pattern
is 9 factorial.
OK.
What about P 60
intersection P 42?
Well, you can think of
this as the same way.
You can think of
this as saying, OK.
I've got an object 60,
I've got an object 42,
and I've got the remaining
digits 1, 3, 7, 8, 9
to permute.
And the sequences of 10 digits
that contain both a 60 and a 42
correspond exactly
to permutations
of the digits 1, 3, 5, 7,
8, 9, and the object 42,
and the object 60.
Now, there's eight of things.
And so the number of
permutations of these eight
things is 8 factorial,
which means the size of P 60
intersection P 42.
The number of permutations
of 10 digits that
have both a 60 and a 42
pattern is 8 factorial.
Now, that's the case of
an intersection where
these two things don't overlap.
Let's look at the case of
P 60 intersection P 04.
Well, if it's got
both a 60 and a 04,
it actually is the
same as having a 604.
So the intersection of P 60 and
P 04 is the set of sequences
that have the pattern 604.
And I count those
in the same way.
I say, OK.
I've got an object 604 plus the
remaining digits-- 1, 2, 3, 5,
7, 8, 9 for a total
of eight objects,
and the number of
permutations of the 10 digits
that half the pattern
604 corresponds
to the number of permutations
of these eight things.
Again, 8 factorial.
OK.
Finally, how many permutations
are there that have all three
patterns-- 60, 04, and 42?
That of course, is
exactly the same
as the set of sequences with the
single pattern 6042, the four
digit pattern.
And again, we count
that by saying
that it's the number
of permutations
of the digits other
than 6042-- six of them
plus the 6042 object.
There are seven of these ,
and so there are 7 factorial
permutations that have
all three patterns.
So that means that I can go
back to my inclusion-exclusion
formula for the sequences
that have one of the three
patterns-- 60, 04, and
42-- and plug them in.
So I get 3 9 factorials for
the first sum of three terms.
The intersections-- we all
figured out each of them
were-- I'm sorry
it's 8 factorial.
So I'm going to subtract
3 times 8 factorial.
And this last term we
figured out was 7 factorial.
Well, I can think of 3 times
9 factorial as 9 times 8 times
3 times 7 factorial, and this
is 3 times 8 times 7 factorial.
And I wind up
[NO AUDIO]
PROFESSOR: 72,720.
That's how many permutations
of the digits 0 through 9
there are that have one
or another of these three
patterns.
Turns out that's about 27% of
the 10 factorial permutations
of 0 through 9.
So that's the significance
of applying the disjunction
of constraints, this union of
having either 60, 04, or 42.